[Music]
all right let's go to sean in las vegas
what's up sean
hi how are you guys outstanding how are
you
i am grateful to be here um so i'm
really glad i actually found you guys
number to call you i have been battling
with this uh i feel like
i'm i'm battling with his blessing
uh we are currently on
baby step two
but my father has gifted us a house me
and my husband which is awesome right
it's like how many people can say that
um but so we're almost out of debt and
then we'll obviously be working on baby
step three and
getting our emergency fund but i think
i just we lose our vision after that for
what's next in our family and so
we were thinking about getting a second
house over where my husband's from which
is he's from washington but i really
don't want to pay the taxes of
washington if we got a second place so
we like the idea of 20 minutes across
the river
into coeur d'alene idaho
and
so we would like to say we have we like
the idea of getting a another house but
then we don't know
how based off of the dave ramsey
suggestions
do we get a loan on a house a 15-year
fixed mortgage do we
try paying it out right it's technically
considered an investment property
because it's not our primary property
so i think we just kind of feel lost on
with what to do with our financial
situation or not so would you rent this
house out or are you just going to stay
there whenever you guys are in town
yeah so we do both i was thinking of
verbaling it and airbnb
it and um
and also going into and obviously
staying there once we're in town okay
so this has my husband has off like four
days a week he's off four days a week
which is awesome so we could go how do
you get that job yeah i want that job
dave makes me work
that job so he works three days a week
three well technically three and a half
but yeah three days a week three full
days three twelve hour shifts i talked
to dave about this yeah i don't know if
we can score that one john 100 so tell
me sean what's your household income
uh we're at about ninety thousand ninety
thousand how much debt do you have left
like uh four thousand oh okay we're
going to get rid of this debt like what
this month next month you
know like in by february for sure why is
it going to take until february to pay
four grand off
well because we also pay property taxes
which are going to be due in january so
does all of america holidays
i know so all of america but then we
have a holiday and a holiday budget
we're trying to get people's christmas
gifts and
that's like a 500 budget
i have a child who is three months old
and she has a i have to make a homemade
formula for her
and it's really expensive
um
unfortunately like she can't handle the
she can't handle regular cow's milk so
she has to have i have to make her a
homemade goat milk formula
um tell me this what's your husband
doing the four days he's off
well he's also in the military so he has
um
he does
he does military uh stuff once a month
he's in the reserves
what does he do those other days
and then the other days he is a um
he's in school finishing up his
bachelor's which we also he's getting it
done for free oh nice he's in the
military that's awesome well he's thank
him for his service
however yeah you're welcome thanks
you're welcome i guess my husband he's
pretty great
um
for me i i then think about what i can
do i'm trying to actually start up my
own business on top of it
i'm working from home and so when i have
the time i
am trying to start so
you guys are are you paying a mortgage
right now are you in a house you're
renting no you got a free house are you
you're already in the free house you got
a free house yeah so you don't have
you have no mortgage payment and you
have no margin
i know and i we have no school debt we
have no are you guys doing an every
dollar budget right now
yeah i've been using the every dollar
budget for like three years i'd be going
through that budget with a fine
uh pick comb going where is all this
money going you make ninety thousand
dollars and you don't even have five
hundred
a thousand dollars in margin
so that's new so
um the five thousand thousand dollars is
or this ninety thousand dollar budget is
just started this month my husband just
got this new job so this should speed up
this speed this this will speed up
things it'll speed it up but then you
know what also recently cut off the
bills why we're not why we're in the
situation right now too is we used to
have two cars
we had a truck and then we had a four
runner and i had a loan on my forerunner
and i owed like 16 000
and um i bought it new well that's of
course what we do people do that
especially with like you don't even have
a house payment you can this is like
your house hang on hang on hang on uh
let's get to the let's answer your
original question we're gonna run up
against the clock and the people who are
saying that they were right
yeah so as far as your actual question
yes it's not you can you can definitely
get a mortgage i would do it the ramsey
way 15-year fixed rate put at least 20
down if you guys can cash flow the whole
thing and pay cash that's amazing uh but
i'm not gonna be mad at you if you do it
this way don't look at it as an
investment property right now because we
have no idea if this thing is going to
bring in a dollar yet just look at it as
we want a second home we want to do it
the right way this is going to be our
only mortgage payment but guess what you
guys can't even afford life with no
mortgage payment right now yeah so
that's what i'm more concerned about
yeah
you're dreaming about a second house
and you've got a three-month-old you've
got a husband who's working here he's
got a full-time job and he's in the
military he's finishing about street i
want you to slow down and enjoy
right now
slow down enjoy the second
and get everything paid off and then get
a fully funded emergency fund and then
start wondering
i wonder if we could buy a second house
and visit a few times and just rent a
place
when you're in that place and then
eventually maybe one day 10 years from
now you go all right we're here enough
that we want to buy a place here
that's what there's there's just a lot
going on here in your life and like
john's saying i think slowing down is
going to help you guys figure out how to
budget properly what does this new
income look like for us what does the
situation for our daughter look like
i think there's there's too much going
on right now for you guys to even be
thinking about buying another property
yeah put that in a that'd be cool one
day i have a bunch of things like that
that it would be cool one day right like
making an album with me probably not but
going to a world series game that would
be cool i'll make an album with you if
it's a rock rack rock rap album rock rap
i'll be in for that not one of your
sad acoustic records all right back to
sean's point
that is a blessing sean that's awesome
get control of your money so it can work
for you not against you and don't let
the future this panic uh should we do
this that is 10 years down the road
let's enjoy
today